and we are counting down to the grammy
awards on eight news now yeah we sure
are you know a lot of people when they
think of hollywood they think it's where
the musicians make all their music but
it turns out las vegas is also kind of a
mecca for recording hits so mary jane
belly has got a behind the scenes tour
of one of the studios in town and where
some of the stars have put together
these these great albums mary jane
yeah i absolutely did heather let me
just say this weekend very exciting to
look forward to very anticipated as the
grammys take place here for the first
time in las vegas and you know as the
city is hosting concerts and residencies
here that also means big albums are
being produced locally here too
for over a decade the omnitone recording
studios has catered to the las vegas
community founder darren shure a
songwriter and music producer says the
goal is to give everybody access to what
goes on behind production and educate
clients on the process of what it takes
to put together a music record and
countless big-name musicians and stars
have also stopped by to record big time
hits with the omnitone crew this
includes grammy award-winning artists
ranging from celine dion to snoop dogg
snoop lived in las vegas for for a short
period of time and when he did i did a
lot of work with him i was very
fortunate and one day he came in the
studio and a happy working on rosalie's
project and he asked if he could take a
listen to it and he did and then a few
months later the contracts came through
and we were lucky enough to work with
the dog father it was it was definitely
a bucket list moment my in my career and
he was a perfect gentleman it was
amazing to work with him sher says
serving the las vegas community is his
way of giving back and providing the
best service he can to help people and
their passion for music
back out here live darren sure tells me
he of course is excited for the grammys
to take place this weekend too and he
says events like these are a really big
impact the art and music community in
las vegas reporting live from the strip
mary jane valeza live local now